it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all that exclusive low discounts so
start shopping now scan the QR code on
your screen right now or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Warner joins us right now let's get
right to it yes this is a rechargeable
purifier yes clean light Air Pro this is
amazing great for all those little cozy
spaces we're going to turn it on it's an
ionic air purifier so this is going to
help kill up to 99 of bacteria and
viruses also get rid of all those odors
so think about all the rooms in your
house or places where the pets are in
the bathroom the kitchen teenagers right
driving the kids home by the way in the
car it's got an adapter you can put this
into your car exactly so this is
designed for up to 120 161 square feet
so we're going to be able to clean up
that air so lightweight breathe a little
easier yes exactly yes so this is a
hundred dollars savings right now
79.99 really amazing okay pixie decade
pets love this our kids want tablet time
my kids always asking well now we can
give it to them because this is a
creative way for them to get involved
first they're going to start off by
drawing a pet they're going to take a
picture of that pet it's going to jump
right into the app that we've downloaded
and then they're gonna have to take care
of their pet cleaning it feeding it
vetting it even playing games
it turns into yes a full video game so
as they care for it they're going to
earn points but I love the creativity
because not only do they have to draw
the pet they have to draw the houses
that they're going to live in they're
going to draw the egg that they hatch
out of so it's a lot of science
technology engineering arts and math
this is a great way for the kids to
learn and have fun at the same time
perfect yes so right now buy one get one
so
24.99 for a set of two of these perfect
gifts yes kids nieces nephews that's
right yes okay raycon now these are
actually our work earbuds I'm going to
let you check these out I love these
because they come with so many great
audio options so we know Ray J he's in
the music industry you know cousin to
Snoop brother with Brandy well he's
designed these with the best audio so
first of all you've got that noise
cancellation so if you're in a room with
lots of things going on you're going to
be able to focus six years yes yes
working out that's right six different
microphones so people can really hear
you well when you're on those work calls
which I love and when you're outside
running jogging you need awareness of
what's around you it also has an
awareness setting so you're going to be
able when I'm out running I want to be
able to hear cars around me here honking
so you can put that awareness setting on
as well so lots and lots of great
features on this right now
89.99 they are 25 off not just good for
work but good for every day there's not
too many products that I have I'm not
gonna lie to you yes Ray J is doing his
thing with these headphones they are yes
the audio it's amazing right it's
amazing all right okay so right now the
cost of dry cleaning is insane we cannot
send everything to dry cleaner every
time we have to iron these are amazing
solutions from ironmatic first is this
mat you're going to be able to put this
on any surface and iron it's got seven
layers put it on a wood table throw it
on your bed small space is amazing yes
and even this to help protect your hand
great solution for small spaces or if
you can't you know open and close maybe
the big ironing board however if you are
looking for like the best ironing board
ever this is it it's got a patented tray
that you can use to put the iron all of
your Essentials your starch your phone
maybe your remote because you know
you're watching a little TV while you're
doing it Great Wide space this is
amazing and the height six different
height differences so good for a little
like me and tall like my hubby well done
all right Elizabeth Warner thank you so
much of course we partnered with all
these companies you can get these deals
scanned the QR code or go to
cbsdeals.com